[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and this is
Heinz knife theory so this is a basic
informative video that kind of outlines
the way outlines the way that I talk
about knife most of the stuffs out there
right now I didn't find to have a good
way to talk about the use of a knife and
what's going on when you're involved
with a knife in self-defense
so this is my outline it's available to
you guys free of charge and so if you
like it great if you don't then there's
no problem that cost you anything if you
really like it a lot we have a patreon
page and you can check out the patreon
page and in on the patreon page there's
more detailed views of everything and
we'll go over everything and find our
detail sub you shouldn't that check it
out otherwise this is a knife system and
the way that I talk about knife and
hopefully will be useful to you guys
thanks a lot alright so first part of
hinds knife theory is you have to
understand there's no such thing as a
knife fight and that's a little bit of
provocative language purposefully but
the basic idea behind that and I'm not
saying that you know historically people
haven't gotten in fights with knives
certainly they have but what you think
of as being a fight where two people are
exchanging and they're able to control
the power the other person's making that
doesn't really exist with knives
and the reason is kind of simple so if
we were in a fist fight so me and Josh
here we were in a fist fight then
basically what we have the same distance
so meaning when josh is able to hit me
I'm able to hit him back now because
josh has the ability with his body to
cover then he can eliminate my ability
to hit him back with as much power as he
hits me so for example Josh let it hit
me and I hit him back he can cover and
defend against that shot right so if he
does a high cover from this bang he can
protect himself from me hitting him as
hard as he's getting me and so if this
fight consists of two people moving
around and both trying to hit each other
and the
he's making the contact doing it in a
way that the other person can't hit him
back his heart right so I could take
clever angles and hit him so it can't
hit me as hard and I can also covering
covering seem to be a really important
skill especially when we're in distance
because of the the speed of the hands
and the speed of the feet we're gonna
talk about that in a later video but
that's basically how a fistfight would
work we can exchange blows because we're
able to neutralize the other person's
blows in a certain way now if we were
doing a sword fight right so a sword
fight we can do the same kind of thing
because in a sword fight I can use the
sword to create what's called opposition
so meaning because Josh and I have the
same reach right meaning if Josh attacks
me I can attack job right and this
course would be a stupid way of using a
sword you wouldn't call it a fight you
can tell it to people murdering each
other so I said Josh Josh that's me bad
idea
so what I want to be able to do is make
attacks on Josh that give me natural
opposition meaning when I'm attacking
this guy his immediate response is
covered by my sword now because of the
length of my sword
I'm able to naturally oppose it now from
this line here you can see even if Josh
was under my sword he misses me while
I'm attacking him so I've created a way
to oppose his sword with the length of
my sword and the angles I'm taking to
keep him from returning that blow now if
we both had knives we can't do the same
thing because our bodies aren't strong
enough to resist the knife so in the
fist fighting scenario when Josh hits me
and I return a shot he can cover to keep
me from hitting him as hard so we can't
do that with knives because every time I
stab him it's gonna be really bad and
returned now he might get me worse but
he's still gonna suffer a bad blow
potentially a fatal blow so we can't
trade at all like we could in a fist
fight with swords I can use the length
of the weapon so we can't trade because
the weapons are powerful but I can use
the length of the weapon to oppose his
weapons with a knife because the weapons
so short I can't really oppose his knife
if we're inside range with the night she
can always return cut me so knives don't
really have a fight in the same sense
that this fight would or a sword fight
would there could be two people in a
struggle one person's are
with a knife and we wouldn't say to have
any knife fight then we're saying the
person who has the knife right so if I
had a knife I would be stabbing Josh
with a knife we're not in a knife fight
we're in a fight where I'm stabbing Josh
vice-versa so be the same with peek at a
knife in return if Josh had a knife that
I had a knife we could be fighting with
it but the truth is really we're
murdering each other is what we're doing
so we can't provide enough opposition we
can't neutralize the other person's
attack so much to make it beneficial to
get into that kind of engagement so the
first thing you got to understand is
that knife fights really don't exist
it's just kind of murdering each other
with knives if you get out of the knife
bite without getting cut severely then
you got lucky but in general you
couldn't make a continuous system that
protects you all the time when there's
knives involved in both of your your
hands so knife fights don't exist that's
the first part of the theory stay tuned
for the next which is the hands quicker
than the foot all right second part of
hinds knife theory so the first part was
talking about how knife fights don't
exist because we don't have the ability
to create opposition we don't bility to
defend ourselves at that range very
nicely from their weapon I can't take
really nice lines and my body's not
strong enough to resist the knife so I
can't really oppose his weapon that way
this part is a game that you need to
play and so this basically will
illustrate how important hand versus
foot speed is and this will also tell us
what the ranges of the knife are and
there's basically in range and out of
range with the knife and those are two
really important ranges to understand so
the first game you're gonna play is
you're gonna get with your partner and a
fingertip distance just like this you're
both gonna stand square I have a rubber
training knife okay
now whatever length of the knife you
have you have to include that in this
minimum safety distance so I have a six
inch knife that's gonna give me a
six-inch reach so we're gonna go ahead
and adjust for that now and if I'm
including a knife we're also gonna have
to account for that in the range what
josh is going to do is he's gonna put
both of his arms behind his back this
way he has no ability to defend himself
with his arms just keeping his arms
behind his back what I'm gonna do is
lunge forward as fast as I can and make
a cut or stab on Josh okay so we'll do
this a couple times you can see
okay so real simple idea we're getting
square standing square and we're seeing
what happens when I try to cover that
amount of distance and he sees what's
going on right so so what's happening is
basically I have to move my body in
because from this distance I cannot
possibly cut him without taking a step
which means I have to use my feet to
move my body forward now when I do that
he's approximating the same speed as I
am so he'll have to move his foot
equally that makes is about equal so
when he sees me gearing up to move he
can take a step and easily get out of
range
our feet are approximately the same
speed and so if I'm that far from him he
can usually get out of the range if you
practice this you'll regularly about 90%
of the time be able to get out of the
range and keep someone from cutting you
even with your hands behind your back
okay now we're gonna see the other side
of this game so we're gonna move in and
now I'm gonna set the knife right at the
shoulder touching distance so now my
knifes right here shoulder touching
distance so this means I no longer have
to take a step to cut Josh I'm gonna
move just as fast as I did before maybe
just as elusive and quickly as I can
with it and he is going to try his best
again to move out of range keeping his
hands behind his back okay so you can
see there every single time I got him
because josh is horribly inefficient at
doing this it's because I have a huge
advantage the arm and hand move way
faster than the foot does so in this
range I don't have to take a step to cut
Josh but josh does have to take a step
in order to avoid the night
so that means I'm at a huge advantage if
I take a cut here really hard for Josh
to get his body out of there before I
can successfully make the cut now this
tells us a really important thing about
knife fighting it tells us that if he's
trying to deal with the knife he wants
to be an excess of arm's length from me
so our
out of range is this for me is the knife
attacker I really don't want to attack
him outside of this range it's gonna be
slow and clumsy and it's gonna be hard
for me to get in there
for him he wants to keep it at this
range or greater so meaning if he sees
me with the knife he always wants to say
greater than this distance that gives
him a really fair chance of being able
to stay out of a range of the knife so
when we're doing this he's gonna stay
out of that range that's his goal
because the nice way more powerful than
his body stopping with his arms and
stuff like that is a bad idea in general
so he's gonna do it with this beat and
if he stays at that range it will be
possible okay
next we're gonna talk about protecting
your vital organs all right third part
in high in snake theory so the first
part we talked about how knife fighting
really doesn't exist and it's
provocative on purpose but if you
haven't seen that video go ahead and
check it out the second part was the
hand is faster than the foot and now
this part we're gonna talk about what
happens when the range has broke down so
from the hand is faster than the foot
video you should be able to gather that
you always want to be greater than
fingertip distance when you're dealing
with someone with a knife now you have
to include the length of the knife with
that so you can see that is now the
distance he has to adjust to when we're
dealing with that and so this means that
when I go to attack I have to take a
step and he has to take a step and that
will get him out of range but if I'm
inside of this he's going to have to do
something to try and keep my hand from
cutting him so meaning that I can move
so fast at this range that he will not
be able to just step out of the way
he'll always be too slow always be
behind and he needs to use his hands and
arms to keep him from getting stabbed
we're gonna call this suppression so
what he wants to do is be able to get
suppression now for Josh he wants to
keep me from cutting any vital targets
so really vital targets for him are
anything functional his biceps and
triceps he doesn't want to get those cut
he gets those cut he loses his function
of his arm that's really really bad he
doesn't want the inside of his forearms
to get cut the ligaments in here are
responsible for closing his hand he
needs to be able to open and close his
hands when we're fighting this is also
arterial meaning that this is oxygenated
blood and if he's losing oxygen blood
more likely to go into shock and pass
so that's bad news he doesn't want to
lose anything in here this is probably
gonna kill him at some point in his life
he might get through this fight but you
know three four hours down the road he's
gonna be in bad shock all kinds of
terrible things are happening in this
guy's body so he doesn't want to get cut
anywhere below his ribs and above his
hip that's all no no spots he also wants
to protect the tops of his quads the
tops his quads get cut then he uses
functionality if you're looking for a
good book on knife targeting I would
recommend Michael Janet his book
contemporary knife targeting kind of
talks about these ideas and gives you
some basic ideas of what you want to get
cut and don't want to get cut now
ideally wants nothing cut but he's
probably gonna have to make a sacrifice
at this range and something's gonna get
cut ideally if anything had to get cut
he wants it to be along the bone on the
outside of his forearm here now the
reason for that is there are no arteries
in here there are no ligaments in here
and no major muscle groups right here so
if the knife comes across that he's
likely to stay highly functional now he
doesn't want to get cut at all but he'll
stay functional if he gets cut in here
so that's the main part of what he's
using when the knife comes in and he's
doing that by simply angling his arm out
as the knife comes in so if the necklace
come in high he'd put his arm up like
this to keep the knife away
if the knife was coming in low he'd put
his arm down like that to keep the knife
away now this means that even if I come
back he's not gonna suffer a severe cut
if he got cut there now look we'd like
to not use the arms that would be ideal
but at this range he's gonna have to use
the arms to protect him if anything
comes up the middle he's gonna cross his
arms and stop it up the middle like this
if anything comes directly from the top
again it cross his arms and stop it from
coming in a top so that's the basic way
he's gonna negotiate this so when I
tried to stab in he's gonna put those
arms down and protect himself he also
wants to work on shrugging his shoulders
by shrugging his shoulders he cuts off a
possibility that I can get in there to
the carotid arteries and he's also gonna
try and keep his elbows around his
midsection so he can always use his
elbow to keep me from getting in there
to the side because I'm coming in you
can stop that with his elbow now we're
gonna run another basic drill where we
see an ethicist and so remember I'm at
the major advantage here when I stab in
he's gonna try and defend himself for me
savvy
okay now you can see still a little
dicey it's scary beneath this range is a
really bad idea you do not want to be in
this range however you need to get your
arms up to protect the vital spots in
your body so you need to get some kind
of suppression so suppression is gonna
lead us to our next really important
keys when we talk about what happens
when you suppress and they try to get
around the suppression in some way so
stay tuned for the next video all right
so this is part four of the video series
on Heinen's knife theory first video we
talked about why knife fighting doesn't
exist second video we talked about how
the hands faster than the foot third
video we talked about how you can
protect your vital organs when you're in
that danger zone right so when you're
inside of range the danger zone what do
you do and how you basically shield them
when your arm reaches out and makes
connection with someone attacking we
call that suppression so my basic idea
here is I want to get the knife to Josh
and he's suppressing my ability to do
that keep me from doing now there's not
a control here meaning he's not holding
my arm my arm can still do whatever but
he's suppressing my attempt to attack
when he suppresses I'm gonna have one of
just a few options when he suppresses I
will either a retrieve the knight so
meaning I pull it back to me so I can
use it again be attempt to go around the
suppression or sea drive through the
suppression those are my options right
those three options are all I have
once he suppresses I'm either gonna
recover the knife I'm going to go around
his suppression or I'm gonna drive
through his suppression those are my
main ideas now he needs to have options
for all of those different ideas so once
he's got suppression he needs to have
options his number one goal would be to
go from suppression to control so if he
suppressed here he would like to
immediately be able to control that
knife in a way so that I can't use it
anymore
now essentially as long as he can keep a
hold to this he's nullified my ability
to use a knight so he's going from
suppression to control that's his number
one if he gets that depends on who's
first to act if we get suppression here
and I'm first to act I'm
to recover go around or drive-thru
before he does anything if we get
suppression and he acts before I act
then he's gonna get the control so he
wants to get to control but once we have
the suppression I've got a few different
options each one of those options will
depend on where we're at in the stage
and we're gonna look at some drills to
work through those after this all right
so we talked to this our fifth video in
the series we talked about all the major
parts of the theory right it's important
understand is just such things a knife
fight and why that's really really
dangerous then moving on to that the
hand is faster than the foot and
understanding that and that's always
gonna factor in to knife situations how
to protect the vital organs when you're
inside of that knife range now that
vital organ protection is called
suppression so from that suppression I
have those three options we talked about
in the last video I'm either gonna
recover the weapon I'm gonna go around
his suppression or I'm gonna drive
through there's only three things I can
possibly do he needs to be able to move
with me if I try to go around so you're
gonna address going around first so if I
move around this he wants to be able to
stick to me no matter what I do so we're
gonna do a real flowy kind of funny
drill now this drill it looks weird and
in a knife situation where you're in
conflict with the knife it would never
look like this but this drill is giving
you a skill set for when they quickly
try to come around you're suppression so
Josh all with you start with suppression
he's not gonna move his feet and I'm not
gonna move Mikey what I am gonna do is
try and sneak around his arm and cut his
body right so as we go here I'm trying
to get in there and cut it what he wants
to do is stick to my hand as I do this
right so I'm moving kind of slow right
now now what I'm not gonna do are my
other options I'm not gonna recover the
knife that's one of my options in this
drill we're not doing it and I'm not
gonna try to drive through so I'm not
gonna be forced to drive through that's
also one of my options but not for this
drill this drill is exclusively about
someone trying to move around your
suppression so you get suppression I try
to have you know you can see it still be
kind of wildly and clever and get all
get in there and really try and get him
that's what I want to do I want to work
him I want to push him to the edge so
it's difficult for him to defend himself
now the first stage
one hand on one hand so we might go for
you know say 30 seconds to a minute
right hand and then 30 seconds to a
minute left hand then we can work a
switching drill so I can switch and then
we can work to switching drill where he
also can use both hands so come in here
now in the suppression drill he's not
gonna get control so you didn't get to a
control position remember that's what
he's mainly working for but in this
drill he's not allowed to do that that's
gonna train these uh when I'm trying to
go around skills so as I move here he's
just trying to stick with it I can
switch and come in try and cut him
wherever I can cut him he's trying to
defend itself now I'm pushing him I'm
going fast purposefully so he'll get
good at this all right now what happens
if they try to drive through instead of
move around check out the next video and
we'll talk about that all right so now
we had a drill for someone trying to go
around your suppression let's add a
drill for someone trying to go through
your suppression so remember once josh
has suppression I have three options
recover the weapon move around his
suppression or push through his
suppression those are my three options
the last show we talked exclusively
about moving around his suppression now
we're gonna add to that moving through
his suppression so what that would look
like is I'm here and I'm not gonna go
around but I'm gonna force the knife in
in a way that goes right into him so
what he's gonna be able to do now is
move his feet so the last drill we
didn't allow him to move his feet and
the reason for that was because we're
setting up that close distance he he got
stuck in however now he can move his
feet in this drill I'm not going to
recover the weapon I'm only going to go
around and press through and he is not
going to attempt to control or
outdistancing
okay so that's the idea you can see
again I'm trying to move fast and I'm
working it when you're working your
partner's you shouldn't go so fast that
they're completely out work right so if
it looks something like this okay you're
going too hard on your partner he can't
process what's going on you want to go
real slow at first and see if he can
process right so right there he's really
easily able to work and that's where I
want to keep him okay now as I want to
make him work harder I just add a little
more speed
I add my targeting I changed my
targeting a little bit but we're playing
basically the same game so when they're
trying to drive through your suppression
you're going to move your feet to allow
yourself to change angles on this okay
so now we am at a drill for moving
around and we've got a drill for someone
trying to push through what about a
recovery drill so what if I recover what
should he do all right so this in this
part we're going to talk a little more
about suppression so we had our first
ideas with suppression remember there's
only three things I can do once he's got
suppression in place then I can recover
I can move around or I can drive through
those are my three options with the
suppression we covered a drill for
moving around and him sticking with me
as I do this we worked a drill where I
try to push through and you can move his
feet to keep himself from getting taken
off now we're going to talk about what
happens when I recover now this is
potentially the most dangerous area for
Josh if I recover my weapon now he has
zero contact with my weapon and this
range
I'm almost certainly going to
successfully stab him right so he has no
contact with me doesn't know what's
going on remember my hand moves faster
than his foot so very likely that I'm
gonna get a successful shot in when Josh
sees me recover he wants to exit the
position right so he wants to create
distance the reason he wants to do that
is because I'm going to win at that
range so if he has any possible way of
getting out of there that's exactly what
he's gonna do the second I recover he's
gonna make distance now the way we're
gonna work this drill is the second he
tries to make distance and he gets there
successfully he's gonna say
reset right so we're gonna play the game
the same and the distance he's trying to
get through hot back for me the distance
he's trying to get through is this
distance or greater right that's where
he knows again that you can see I'm
coming and he can deal with me so what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna be at
this range we're gonna start the drill
runs exactly the same as before except
sometimes I'm gonna try to recover my
weapon reset okay so as soon as he gets
out of that space he's gonna try and
reset that distance we start here again
from suppression I work reset okay the
second he sees me get here he's getting
to distance and saying reset now the
reason he's doing that is because he
wants to train himself not to go into a
defended position here's what I mean by
that when I'm set up like this we call
this position defense I am in a defended
position when he comes in he'll hit my
hand before he can control the knife
which means I can pick and choose when I
attack him here as he reaches in I can
cut at him I can cut in his arms I can
cut in his body and I can protect my
knife the whole time it's a losing
proposition for him to try and push in
on the fence this fence keeps him there
the only choice he has is to get away
from the defended position he needs to
get out of there this is why it becomes
really deadly if I managed to grab him
or hold him from this kind of position
super bad position to be in but if you
can possibly avoid it you're gonna make
distance the second my weapon recovers
he's going to make distance and he's
saying verbally reset and the reason
he's saying this because he's training
himself not to run back into a defended
position the last thing you want to do
on a guy who has a knife he's got
superior weapon to you is run in on it
right so don't run it into his dependent
position and this drill right now is
teaching you to think about that and say
reset when you get yourself back to the
safe position check out the next drill
we'll talk about going to control
alright so we've talked now about the
safety distances and suppression and
what he needs to do right so so just to
recap real quick this guy needs to make
sure that he's never in this close range
this close range is bad because my arm
will move so fast that I'm likely to get
a cut on it he wants to always try and
keep the distance set to here now if I
were to
and he couldn't get his feet out of the
out of there right so he can't move his
feet fast enough to move himself out
he's gonna use suppression to stop my
knife
now the second we get suppression if I'm
quicker to act than he is I'm gonna do
one of three things I'm gonna recover my
weapon I'm gonna go around his
suppression or I'm gonna drive through
his suppression those are the only three
options I have you need to train
yourself to deal with all three of those
in different ways if I recover his main
idea is that he wants to get out of
there and make distance whenever he does
that he's gonna say reset so that way we
know that he's thinking I need to get
myself out of here this is a potentially
dangerous situation so now we're gonna
work with his ability to make control so
remember what I said it's it he gets
suppression and he's first to act he's
gonna get control of this knife that's
what he wants to do here because he is
now got the weapon and I can't do
anything with it I can't use the knife
against him at this moment so control is
really his goal from suppression before
weren't allowing him to get that so that
way you can train the skill sets if I
have to go around it if I try to go
through it or if I try to recover now
we're gonna let him get that control so
as we go if he gets the control he gets
the control I however I'm also still
gonna be working going around the
suppression through a suppression and
recovering my weapon we're gonna start
from a suppression point and now from
here once I start it he can get control
whenever he wants
reset okay now that was a great example
he went here I pushed down I pulled out
and recovered my weapons he saw going
into me was a bad idea
so he stepped back and reset that
okay now that's another good example he
managed to get in there lock the note
nice tight to him and control it so I
couldn't get it free okay from there
we'd work into grappling positions we'll
have a video just on grappling so you
can check that out but getting control
has to happen before the grapple if
we're here and Josh doesn't have control
he goes into grappling maybe he's gonna
bear hug me or something he's getting
stabbed for all this he cannot afford to
grapple with me unless he first has
control of the night so remember our
hierarchy here right he wants to always
keep me this distance or greater if I
somehow trick him and encroach on this
distance he's gonna have to use his
hands to stop me from cutting him from
here he suppressed me I'm gonna have if
he's the first act then he'll get
control if I'm the first act either I'm
gonna go around his weapon and he needs
her around his suppression and he's
gonna need drills from that I'm gonna
recover my weapon and he needs to know
to reduce sense from that or I'm gonna
try and drive through with my weapon and
he needs drills for that so now we've
set up all the basic ideas and getting
to the control the move to grappling in
a bit but we're gonna recap all of this
stuff so you can kind of get a good idea
of it check out the next video okay so
this is gonna be our recap here at the
midway point so there's still lots of
material to talk about but just to kind
of reinforce the ideas we've been
talking about and make sure they're
clear in your mind you can't fight with
a guy with a knife even if you have a
knife if you have a superior weapon you
can fight with them it's really again
not a fight because you have the
superior weapon so you're gonna be
taking charge of that but you really
can't afford to fight with a knife it's
dangerous you're gonna get cut a bunch
it's bad news so what do you do if
someone has a knife and you don't write
the first thing you want to do is make
sure you stay at this distance
now this fingertip distance is important
because without taking a step I can't
possibly cut this guy if I take a step
he's gonna be approximately the same
speed as me and he can take a counter
step which means he's gonna be well out
of that distance now when he took that
counter step notice we again reset to
this distance so if he can manage to
keep me there the whole time and
negotiate what's going on that's best
for him so if I'm some freak oh and I
pulled out
nice somewhere and I'm running around a
building trying to stab this guy what he
really should be trying to do is keep
that fingertip distance right by being
able to do that
I can't surprise him all of a sudden now
what happens if I get inside of this
distance if I get inside of this
distance my arm moves faster than his
feet so if he only tries to step out of
the way he's probably gonna get cut
every time you can play a game and learn
how that works
so he's also going to have to protect
his vital areas all he's doing he's not
trying to reach out and grab my knife
all he's doing is protecting his vital
areas while I try to stab in there so as
I'm coming in with a knife he's really
trying to protect himself from the knife
we call this suppression when he gets
the suppression in here either he's
gonna be first to act or I'm gonna be
first to act if he's first act he wants
to control the night if I'm first to act
I have three options one is recover the
knife
two is go around his suppression three
is strike through his suppression
those are my three options this guy
needs drills for each of those in order
to stay safe
suppression moving around the
suppression he's gonna learn to stick to
my arm now remember he would be trying
in a real fight to get control at any
time he's not going to be doing that
silly thing over and over
boy he's doing he's learning split
decision decision-making so that that
way when I come in he can suppress and
keep me away then he needs a drill if I
push through for this he's gonna
practice moving his feet as he holds
that suppression so if I'm driving
through he's gonna keep the suppression
move his body to avoid him getting
knocked around blast on this is it from
the suppression I recover my weapon
before he can act he's gonna outdistance
me right and reset the original distance
we were in so you can see that's our
basic outline now we're gonna move
beyond this so what happens when you're
at the distancing what are the skill
sets you're gonna need to stay at that
distance and then what happens if you
get the control and you go into
grappling what kind of skill set you're
gonna need in the grappling range so
we've outlined a few important things
for you guys one is you can't fight with
a knife it's too powerful the range is
too short there's no length in the
weapon to protect you your hand moves
faster than your foot so if they're
trying to stab you you can't outdistance
them if they're close to you already
once you get suppression you
get controlled but if you don't they're
gonna do one of three things recover the
weapon move around your suppression or
drive through your suppression you need
skills you need drills for each one of
those to develop your skills along the
way so keep watching and we'll talk
about the other areas as we go I'm Chris
Ryan thanks a lot